صخرة كونية عمرها 4.5 مليار سنة على وشك
الهبوط على الأرض، هذه المركبة الفضائية كما
ترون هناك تحمل عينة من
الصخور والغبار من كويكب اسمه
بينو وتدخل الغلاف
الجوي للأرض بسرعة 36 ضعف
سرعة الصوت في العينة  إن
الهبوط في هذا الجزء المقفر من
صحراء يوتا أمر مهم لأن
بينو عمومًا كويكب بحجم
مبنى إمباير ستيت، ولديه
فرصة حقيقية للاصطدام بالأرض خلال 159
عامًا، وإذا حدث ذلك بالفعل فإنه
سيضرب الأرض بقوة  22
قنبلة ذرية، لذا تأمل وكالة ناسا أن تساعدهم هذه العينة
التي حصلوا عليها في
اكتشاف طريقة لمنع الاصطدام
ومعرفة الكثير بشكل أكثر وضوحًا عن
الكويكبات الموجودة في المقدمة، والآن عالم الفيزياء الفلكية
نيل ديجراس تايسون هو رئيس قبة
هايدن السماوية  مضيف برنامج Star
Talk وقد كتب للتو كتابه الأخير
إلى اللانهاية وما بعد رحلة
الاكتشاف الكوني، لذلك من الواضح أن نيل
أستمتع بكل محادثاتنا، لذا
لديك هذا الكويكب وأنت تعلم
أنه أمر لا يصدق بكل الرياضيات التي
نحصل عليها  هناك، احصل على قطعة صغيرة من الصخرة
بواسطة الروبوت وقد أحضروها إلى المنزل، فما الذي
يمكن للعالم أن يتعلمه بالفعل من
هذه الصخرة التي يبلغ عمرها 4.5 مليار عام والتي على
وشك الهبوط في ولاية يوتا،
حسنًا، ما لا نعرفه على وجه اليقين عندما
تعتقد أننا سنفعله  ولكننا لا نعرف
ما هي السلامة الهيكلية
للكويكبات، في العقود الأخيرة فقط،
علمنا أن بعضها قد يكون مجرد
أكوام من الأنقاض متجمعة معًا والتي
تتنكر في هيئة جسم صلب، والبعض الآخر متماسك
بشكل غير محكم معًا، هذا
أمر مهم لأنه إذا أردت  لصرف
كويكب قد يكون في
طريقك ودفع جزء منه
وليس لديه سلامة هيكلية
للبقاء معًا، يمكن أن ينتهي بك الأمر إلى كسر
قطعة وستفشل مهمتك
بعد ذلك، لذا من خلال النظر إلى ما
المحتويات المادية لـ benue هي من خلال
نموذج الإرجاع هذا والذي بالمناسبة علينا
فقط أن نمدح أن هذا
يعمل بشكل جيد فقط أعني فقط انظر، لقد فعلت ذلك،
يجب أن أقول إننا أطلقنا
هذه المهمة من osiris-rex منذ سبع سنوات
من منصة متحركة
تقاطعت الأرض مع هدف متحرك بينو
وكويكب، ولمست ثم عادت
المواد التي تم التقاطها إلى الأرض ونشرت
تلك الكبسولة، وهي تستمر في الذهاب،
ستزور المزيد من الكويكبات ثم
يقول الناس أوه، أنا لا أثق في
العلم، سأكون كذلك  قول هذا، هل
تعرف ما الذي نفعله، هل لديك أي
فكرة،
أعني أنه أمر لا يصدق، ثم
هناك أيضًا يا إلهي يمكننا فعل ذلك ويا لها من
فوضى نحدثها
بالعديد من الأشياء البسيطة هنا في المنزل
حسنًا، حسنًا،
إذا ضرب بينو الأرض،
وأنا أعلم أنه من الواضح أنه
يمكننا التحدث عن الاحتمالات، لكن إذا
كنت تتحدث عن شيء ما 22 مرة،
فهذا ما قلته 22 مرة 22 مرة
بحجم أو 22 قنبلة ذرية  اسمحوا لي أن
أتأكد من أنني أقول ذلك بشكل صحيح تمامًا، ما الذي
يمكن أن يفعله شيء كهذا بالأرض؟ حسنًا،
إنه ليس مستوى الانقراض، أه
ضربة جيدة إذا ضرب مدينة
سيئة للغاية ولكن سيكون لدينا فكرة جيدة عن
ذلك مسبقًا بحلول الوقت المناسب  ومع
اقترابنا من 2182، ستتحسن هذه الاحتمالات،
بمعنى أنها
إما ستذهب إلى الصفر أو ستصل إلى اليقين،
ولن تظل معلقة هل هي كذلك أم
لا، وهذه
نقطة أولى مهمة، لذلك إذا كنا  أعلم أنها
ستضرب، فسنعرف
أين ستضرب إذا ضربت
مدينة فإنها ستدمر المدينة بالكامل
ولكن معظم الأرض ليست مدينة، لذا فإن
معظم الأراضي غير مشغولة،
لذا فإن خوفي هو أنه إذا  تضرب المحيط
ثم تحصل على تسونامي يمكن أن
يدمر خطًا ساحليًا بأكمله ولكن
بخلاف ذلك فإنه سيدمر ما
يعادل مساحة الأرض في المقاطعة لذا كما تعلم
أتمنى أن يحصل الجميع على
كتابك الجديد الذي تتحدث فيه عن الكلمات المتوازية الثقوب
السوداء في العوالم  الثقوب الدودية السفر عبر الزمن
كل هذه الأسئلة لدى الناس شيء واحد يتحدث
عنه الكثير من الناس
مؤخرًا، وحتى الآن لدى وكالة ناسا
وجهة نظر حول الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة، صحيح أن الكونجرس لديه جلسة
استماع حول الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة ولذا كان الناس
يتحدثون عن الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة والكائنات الفضائية في
بطريقة أكثر جدية مما تعلم، أن تكون على
واجهة مجلة National Enquirer
بالطريقة التي كانت عليها من قبل، حيث
عرض صحفي مكسيكي جثتي شخصين
مفترضين من غير البشر أه في
المكسيك أمام الكونجرس في
المكسيك، حسنًا
أم كل واحد  بثلاثة أيدي أصابع
ورؤوس ممدودة الآن قبل أن نسخر جميعًا من
الفيديو لأنه
تعرض للكثير من السخرية، فهو يبدو كثيرًا
مثل E.T ولكن كما قلت،
أعلنت ناسا للتو لأول مرة أنني
مدير أبحاث الأجسام الطائرة المجهولة  لذا فهم
يأخذون أه هذا الموضوع بشكل أكثر
جدية، ما هو رأيك في هذا
جيدًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أحب ما فعلوه
في المكسيك، حيث كان لديهم ما زعموا أنها
أجسام غريبة وقاموا بعرضه
أمام الكونجرس، وهذا أفضل
من تركهم في  صندوق مغلق
ويقول أنت ولا يمكن لأي شخص آخر
رؤيتهم، لذا فهذه بداية ولكن في
العلم حقيقة جديدة يتم
إثبات الحقيقة الموضوعية فقط عندما تتمكن
مختبرات متعددة من تحليل ما تدعيه
عندما أحضرنا الصخور من القمر وقمنا
بتوزيعها  أرسلوها إلى جميع مختبرات
العالم، لذا شارك الجميع في
هذا الاكتشاف، لذا قم بإحضار عينات للآخرين
ودع الأشخاص الآخرين المتشككين
في مختبرات أخرى يختبرون هذا جيدًا
سواء تم التحقق منه أو تزويره، ثم
ننتقل إلى ما كان رد فعلك عندما
رأيت  الصور
لقد فوجئت لأنه إذا
كانوا من كوكب آخر فلماذا
يبدون بشريين إلى هذا الحد ولديهم عينان وأنف وفم وأكتاف وورك وعظم فخذ
وضلع لماذا
تشترك معظم الحياة على الأرض في الحمض النووي
معنا، فهي لا تشبهنا أبدًا، فكيف  هل
يمكن لشخص ما أن يكون هذا هو
أول ما فكرت به ثانيًا أم
أي جثث أو بقايا محنطة
لا يوجد عظم في أنفك، إنه
ثقب مفتوح في جمجمتك، هؤلاء الفضائيون
لديهم أنوف سليمة، حسنًا إذا كان هذا هو
أنفهم بالفعل، حسنًا بالتأكيد،
هذا جيد  من الغريب بعد ألفي عام أن لا يزال
لدينا أنف به اثنان
وتجويفان، لذلك هذا غريب ولكن
يجب أن يشاركوه بهذه الطريقة
نحدد ما هو صحيح وما ليس على ما
يرام نيل شكرًا جزيلاً، من الرائع
التحدث إليك،
شكرًا  لاستضافتي